not all of it who know stop the script
had a very rich kind of journey to make
with the costumes and Tim really wanted
it to have a real fantasy element to
when she went down the rabbit hole and
this dress is this sort of original kind
of tribute to Alice it's the demure
dress of the period but when she falls
down the rabbit hole she shrinks out of
it and leaves sheds it like she
sheds that world and then when she
really really her cocoon dress and she's
got all her layers here that are great
for you know for animation when she goes
down the hole so you know you get little
kicks of color and pattern and stuff in
in her costume this this dress worked on
the green screen but it also worked in
the real world the technology so much
better now there aren't a lot of
research and sometimes if something's
too shiny it reflects the green but that
wasn't a issue with this I have layers
of fabric that catch the light rather
than reflect it which gives it kind of a
glowing quality which I like to use use
the Cotton's if you must but close
there's enormous girl I took you know
the elements of the Red Queen's court
for this dress because it's a dress
that's made from her curtains and sort
of gave it a wild kind of slightly
contemporary twist like you know the the
minions kind of made it it's it's got a
kind of wildness to it and just thrown
together quality that's young I think
fun Crispin Glover is sort of the Red
Queen's henchman sort of he's her
creature as they say and he's just so
like weird and strange in the movie I
think he's really great and his costume
wasn't originally going to be all
animated but it wasn't kind of working
right in the way the textures and stuff
with the Red Queen and so Tim had me
make a costume Crispin actually never
really wore this costume he wore the
green unitard the whole time he worked
and I made this after and then they put
put it on him and the real you know the
real character is kind of like stretched
out so this
Jim was made but then it's kind of
stretched by the animators but but by
using all these elements it just made it
real and it made it work better in the
world of her costume in her court
costume we just put it on another sort
of body double type guy to to make it
and then they scanned it and put it on
to his care they do it with with films a
bit with superhero stuff especially it's
something that's that's become more
possible I think in the last few years
but now we will back you see and we need
to get onto the frabjous day we did
research on Hatter's and what they took
used to make hat so we had the all those
things around
I've always loved like the idea of a
cross body sort of thing and I had this
idea to just use and I've always loved
these little tiny spools of thread that
are so beautiful the colors they're old
silk red and so I got a bunch of them
and figured out a way to wire them and
make sort of a useful kind of necklace
of them like a the Hatter's Bandolero
and then these ribbons or ribbons that
you could use in hat making all these
are elements that that that you would
actually use in making a hat his
waistcoat Saul got you know layers of
detail that as these our theory was as
he's waiting for Alice he kind of does
sneaks to his own clothes as he's
sitting there at the Tea Party waiting
for her to come back
I think Tim and I both really want to
even though we've worked together we
don't ever want it to get stale so we
always try to find new you know new
ideas and new things to bring into it
and live it keep it alive and and it
seems to be working for us
Oh